is very tiny we sleep on this single bed
this is obviously our goal is to move
into our own place
i love you so much and i love this
apartment it's
so perfect are you serious
i love you so much i love you i love you
i love you i love you see you later
i love you really really really wanna
you know really at the end of the week
you know give her something back for
everything that she's done for me like
literally
this girl has been there when i was
nothing but overweight lost loss a bit
of hair
literally had no money like nothing you
know um
you know so i definitely owe a big time
i just really want to give her something
back
i'm just really frustrated as we really
need that own place
this is what i've been praying for big
luxury apartment skyline views if it's
as good as that if it's as good as that
i'm excited
all right let's go view it cool
i really like this building you know
this is the nicest building here well
he's looking for an apartment to move
into
all right perfect so are you gonna join
us yeah for sure
the living room we've got a different
view of the london actually the canary
wall and the city
in his face is quite happy with it he
loves it
he loves it evans would you like to live
here
oh man i'd love to live here have you
have you ever told uh
ellen i haven't even told ellen i
wouldn't tell her anything
he wants he wants to he wants to
surprise he wants to surprise his uh his
girlfriend
been good it's been tough we'll fill you
in we'll see you on sunday at my house
for some for some
lunch and we'll fill you in on exactly
what's happened thank you so much see
you on sunday yeah
as i said i'd love to get my house or be
in one of my apartments in london but
i'll drop you a dress near the time
i'm so excited thank you all right see
you later princess bye bye
bye bye she has no idea
okay so we've just made an appointment
at my house or
at one of my apartments in london yep um
actually she's gonna be meeting evans in
your new
swanky london home what we're gonna do
i'm thinking
show around as if it's my partnership
but oh she's so nice and then you can
give her the keys and go
welcome home baby welcome home baby
we've also made out that the week has
been a bit crap yeah oh it's been
tough and she's oh i love you anyway
evans don't you worry
but actually it's been amazing so when
you get there
uh give me a call i'll come down and
we'll let you in
all right do you think that she suspects
anything at all no there's no way
there's no way she'd believe that i put
i pulled this out of the bag in a week
like no way she didn't know she should
ever have anything so when she gets to
the apartment
we're just going to say it's my
apartment we wanted to have a debrief
with you
come on up she'll come up you don't
think she'll suspect
and then when she gets up go up to the
apartment and then
i'll let you do your thing and tell them
what yeah
this is this is sick i can't believe i'm
going to be living here bro this is sick
you know look at that
get out
because i've told her this is my
apartment and i want to have a meeting
with her
okay so so she's going to so she's going
to come up
and she'll think it's mine but then when
she gets there
show me evans and evans will say this is
our new home baby
get ready to move in all right this
morning personally came here i literally
cleaned
every single
she's got no idea what she's about to
see
baby this is crazy
there she is hello princess
[Music]
let's go this week was hot
they've been asking me so many questions
like how's everything done yeah
i'm glad that your dad agreed so this is
he's gonna do he's gonna show you that
he's gonna show it around
okay i know have a quick difference
welcome to my apartment thanks wow this
is something
i know it's great got to see so
it's been a good week so we thought we'd
give you a little bit of an update
he's made some good money now you'll be
really pleased yeah so i think this is
what
all right you got the view in here as
well he's making some sick money here
you can see everything yeah and uh
i think that's the bigger room so it's
the two best service service
accommodation
look at that i gotta use my love level
you can pretty much don't have done we
always said we wanted someone with a
view
yeah i'll get there one day i'm getting
on the inshallah
okay so let's go on tweet this one yeah
so yeah that's pretty much
it and i'm gonna let you guess how much
i make on the apartment in a minute
oh gosh that's gonna be so hard to get
well this apartment actually
um well guess how much i make on it a
month i can't guess i don't know
a month so do you do a service
accommodation or this property
i'll tell you exactly how much i make on
this property i make
nothing on this house and the reason i
make nothing
is this is our house this is where we're
gonna be staying
this is our apartment what do you mean i
just want to thank you for everything
you're gonna make me cry um are you
helping me from like
from the bottom and i just want to let
you know that you know i got you for
life
so we've secured this this is our home
[Music]
i love you so much and i love this
apartment it's
so perfect are you serious for real
sarah
what do you mean this is our apartment
what do you mean
and we have a just so you know we have a
gym downstairs we have a sauna
we have a pool and we have a jacuzzi
when we have a sky lounge upstairs
view in the entire of london and this is
exactly what we said we wanted it was
exactly like the plan
everything and in one week i told samuel
and it really happened so it's not me
samuel
oh my god i don't know what to say i
never
ever would have guessed this no way ever
would i guess this
i feel like i thought you would do well
but like was not like this
why don't you look round again with
fresh eyes knowing that this is your
apartment
come on have a look again
[Laughter]
our double bed for the first time we
haven't got to sleep in a single bed
ever again
and we have a bedside table normally we
use like the laundry bag
[Laughter]
i mean i'm not here at all i'm like on
the skies at the moment so happy that i
see samuel
i mean he was a hero for me from the
beginning just take this one yeah he was
my hero
all right it was really lovely to see
i'm gonna go wait in the car now let
these lovebirds do their thing
my job is done
[Music]
is it too good
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my goodness amanda what do you think
of the apartment
i absolutely love it it's just beautiful
the view i'm you know the view is just
could
could you live here yeah i i could
literally
outside of the this fabulous apartment
like on the property side obviously we
did a lot of deals
yeah how have things been since what
have you done since
we finished the challenge a couple weeks
ago yeah well today actually
i quit my job oh my goodness
and she can do that comfortably because
as you've seen the restaurants are going
very nicely looking over two thousand
pounds
of the calendar month yeah you made over
sixteen thousand pounds
in packaging and seven zero thousand and
the bro
is going very nicely and on top
uh we've got a huge development in the
pipeline so honestly saying believe me
when i say that this week i've been with
you
has dramatically changed my life for i'm
so grateful
it's like the most incredible outcome
in the short amount of time absolutely
to
financial freedom oh yes well done
what do you think oh my gosh i knew that
he was gonna become financially free
because obviously spending the week with
you
okay but the extent of how successful
he's actually like made it and like
where he's living how much money he's
made
is insane i know i'm impressed it's
incredible i'm impressed you know what
he deserves
everything he's got that guy he's a good
guy he's got a good woman
so i'm over the moon i'm over the moon
it feels like
a lifetime ago just crazy to think three
weeks ago
we couldn't even like sam couldn't even
stay on our floor
and now we've got this gorgeous central
london apartment we've got a spare room
for samuel to stay
so much has happened in that short time
i mean i've left now left my job
thanks to you yeah now you know it's
actually it hasn't been easy to be
honest
in fact the week was probably one of the
most hardest weeks
but at the same time one of the best
weeks i've ever had
we signed up with racism and tons and
tons of rejection
but we kept on going and um and now
i mean now we're financially free
[Music]
between